hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
so today i'm here to make a midweek
update guys on amc
because we broke out from the triangle
as expected i told you
and i have a lot of very interesting
things i want to show you today and i
hope that after this video as usual guys
you would have
learned something so let's get into it
[Music]
guys so let's start on the first time
frame as usual so let me quickly remind
you what i was saying in my last video
so i did my last video over the weekend
so it was on friday's close
around 49 and i was telling you that i'm
breaking down
this move up that started since
we have the huge breakout i call it the
huge breakout because this was the
biggest resistance we had so of course i
was even bullish before but since then i
was
very bullish i knew the strong move up
would come soon i used fibs
to give you the targets where you guys
had some reactions
so 35 26 then i said 65 75 and then
then i told you guys that we're probably
gonna correct to 35 we went to 37
and we having this triangle pattern here
that i showed you a few times in my
previous videos
so my perfect scenario was this one
one two three four five
all right so my private scenario was the
one that is happening because
as you guys see so this is the idiot
wave
book guys rewritten by uh preston frost
so as you can see in this chapter on
triangles triangle contain five
overlapping waves that survived
three three three three three and a
label abcde
all right so i'm using all this
information this
theory by elliot to actually count my
waves
and try to predict when the
consolidation would be over
so this is the reason why here i
actually told you guys that my perfect
scenarios will break out right away
then we correct i'm gonna come to this
very soon this is actually the very
interesting part of this video so i'm
coming to it very very soon
i knew the breakout would probably occur
that then we would correct and do
three four five so the questions you
guys having is are we gonna correct
before the strong move up
and if yes to which level and when
is the strong move up gonna happen is it
before the unexpiry or after so i'm
gonna try to answer
all these questions in this video so to
do that
i need to zoom in now making a shorter
term analysis
and you're gonna see why i need to zoom
in and many things i want to show you
guys here i'm gonna try to be
as quick as possible because i want to
show you everything
okay even more so basically i need to
analyze my first wave
i need to analyze this wave and i'm
going to apply idiot wave theory again
inside this wave guys so once again
elliott wave theory is for me the
complete
guide to take positions on the market
but to master
this theory you need first to understand
all the other
techniques that we can use in technical
analysis which is support
resistance first moving averages trend
lines
then comes the breakout techniques you
can use fibs as well to find targets and
even to enter some trades
and you need to be aware that
divergences are very
precious information as well that you
can use to know when a reversal is gonna
come
and here i'm gonna show you very soon we
have a little divergence so first
you do your counting so one two
three four five okay
quite easy right it's just very smooth
so you can see from this information as
usual the third wave is the one
that is going to break some major levels
so here the breakout level
you usually have some increase in the
volume so you can see here
of course it's where you have the more
volume you also have some
more volume here but the stronger volume
over the last week
was during this breakout so it's
confirming that it is a breakout
and not a fake out guys if you have a
low volume during your breakout it's
probably that your trend line
is not done properly and that actually
it's not a breakout
just a strong move but if you don't have
the volumes associated
with the breakout you something is wrong
in your drawings
so here i know that this is confirming
that my breakout is correct this is in
the third wave and look we have even
something more interesting
is that the third wave can be itself
broken down into five waves
all right so the third wave is here
extended
keep it like this okay so here the third
wave is extended and guys look what i
want to show you so okay one two
one two three four five four five all
right third wave
is extended is uh broken down in five
waves here as well
and look i go back to my bible so here
you have a few examples of what ratio we
usually see
when for example the third wave is
extended or the fifth wave or the first
wave
so we you have here three examples
so in the first example the third wave
is here extended
so you have one then you have two and
then one two three four five and then
four and five
in this configuration usually the first
wave
uh length is the same as the fifth wave
lengths all right so
you when you know that the third wave is
extended you know that the fifth wave is
going to measure
roughly the same length as the first
wave so this is very precious
information so now i'm not going to
develop here
through the second and third example but
they're good to use as well so have a
look at this guys
once again this pdf uh you can find it
on
google you just type elliot wave pdf
from thrust and presta
and you click on the second or third
link and if you want to get more
information
guys you just click on the link in the
description of my video because this is
a sum up of this book and i think i made
it very accessible for you guys to
understand
even if you are new to technical
analysis and if you are a confirmed
trader in technical analysis i'm sure
you're gonna find some good information
as well so this is for everybody
anyway so here i'll go back to the
charts and look guys
so here i know the third wave is
complete one two three four five
and then if i want to have information
so i'm just going to use fibs
because it's very visual and you can see
yes the perfect symmetry so
let me get rid of what is inside okay so
i'm going to keep this
like this for now i'm going to 30
minutes time frame and here
you can see that basically the first
wave measure from
39 to 46 something so it's like seven
points
and the fifth wave start from 58
plus seven should go to 65 and it's
going to 64. all right so you can see
that this information here was very
accurate
so here we know that we have completed
our fifth wave we have all the
information we want
we could break it down into five waves
inside which we found the third wave is
extended and
we follow the ratios that are the usual
ratios which means wave one equal
wave five in terms of lengths then what
else do we have guys i told you just
before about divergences it's a very
precious tool
look at here guys look at here so let me
get rid of this by the way look guys
how the fibs levels are magnets all
right
it was a magnet here the 33.6 percent
was a magnet
the 44.5 here same it was going around
it
and inside of course this was the third
wave so very impulsive so didn't have
time to
consolidate around those levels but we
might still see some reactions for
example here at 52
i'm gonna come to this very soon guys we
coming here you're gonna have my view
so i'm gonna keep this i'm gonna keep
this as well
for now false wave goes here and so now
guys divergences you remember how it
works right
you just connect the highs of the price
action and of your momentum indicator
and you try to see if you have something
that is not going in the same direction
here market making higher highs from
three
to five market making higher highs look
at the mcd guys
macd making lower highs what does it
mean now you know guys
you know it's a bearish regular
divergence
it's this one all right markets making
higher highs but the momentum indicator
is actually decreasing so we have a loss
of momentum we are losing steam
bulls are losing confidence they are not
able to take
as much ground as before this is the
reason why the momentum indicator is
going down
so it's an early signal of a reversal so
coming back to the charts we're having
here our five waves complete
they really look like five waves we have
the breakout the third wave is breaking
out
and is associated with strong volume
we're now having this
small i call it smoke because we're only
30 minutes time frame
look guys if i gonna hourly time frame
do i still have a divergence
here guys tell me look at this look at
the macd
guys is it going lower
so we don't have a divergence on the
hourly timeframe we only have a
divergence under 30 minutes time frame
here the magnet is going lower what is
this telling us this is telling us that
we are going to have
a very short-term bearish move that is
going to happen
and that is going to be my abc guys my
abc that i was expecting here
so i have all the signals that are
telling me that this market
would correct slightly so it can just
happen in one or two hours it can be
very quick and it doesn't need to be
very deep
so here is my scenario guys okay
a b c
easy right once you understand how the
market is actually unfolding which is
following
the elliot waves you know you have here
enough information
to make this scenario your preferred
scenario so i think
then you can use fibs so 52 is a level
that would make sense
of course you can also here on the 30
minutes time frame you have the 200
moving average but the 30 30 minutes
time frame is not very
nice time frame to use i mean it's not
the basic time frames the basic ones
are the daily four hours and hourly so
we go back on the four hours
and then here we know that the moving
averages they are more powerful because
they are followed by
more traders and so here what do you
guys see you see that you have the 20
period moving average
funny the 20 period moving average look
wasn't it the one that i told you guys
that is supporting the price during the
strong move up we had here and that is
actually my training
stop-loss my kind of signal that the
market is making a pose
yes it's this one you see so again
so i can find it as well with the hourly
timeframe and taking the 50 period
one it should be roughly the same okay
so basically those
are giving me the same level so the 50
period on the hourly goes to 52
the 20 goes to 51 the fibs go to 52.
so we have enough information guys 51 52
somewhere here right it's probably gonna
be the levels we're gonna correct
two we might also see only correction to
55
the 38.2 but i doubt this would be the
case because i'm still missing my c
wave setting 51 of 52 coming
today guys i'm gonna post this video at
the open so it's coming today
once again it can be very sharp and then
strong rebound an alternative scenario
is that
this abc is deeper and that we go as low
as 45 this is kind of my lower level
the 78.6 45 and it's
as well gonna be the support created
by the old resistance which was the
upper band of my triangle
so this is support as well so my two
levels are
52 let's call it 52 and 45
but 52 is my preferred scenario all
right so we go to 52 then we strongly
bounce back
i think this is what is gonna happen we
can also have an extension in in the
fifth wave but it's very unlikely as we
have
divergence under 30 minutes time frame
but we don't have it on the hourly so
you know it can still happen
it can still happen but sometime we
would need to correct here before making
the stronger move up
and i'm pretty sure that this is what is
happening so maybe we only gonna go to
55 but
i doubt it as well all right quickly
the financial data guys so the option
market
very very interesting so here we were at
50 last time i did it so we were at
19 of short interest we are now at
58. so 20 look guys the 145 strike
remember the 3 million one week ago
three days ago it was eight million
and today in in terms of millions of
share
13 million where is it coming from it's
coming from half
is coming from june and the other half
is coming from july
and all the other maturities so this
means
that if the move doesn't absolutely need
to happen
in before june because even after june
we still have those 145
calls that are going to give us some
buddhist momentum on the upside
and something i want to show you guys
here before i conclude on this
think it's interesting to look at the
delta as well this is something
i like to do so you can see that the
delta of the 145 strike hole
for the june maturity is zero guys all
right i use black shorts formula as
usual guys it's
here it's not rocket science and the
delta is zero but the delta of the july
maturity
is 41 so this is giving you some
indication about what market makers are
pricing
and as far as i'm concerned i think that
145
would be difficult to reach i mean my
target is 135
it would be difficult guys to reach
before 18th of june which is
roughly here but it's possible all right
we could still
see this it's possible but it's a bit
unlikely
and we still have the gamma that we need
after the gene maturity so that we still
have this bullish momentum as i just
showed you guys this gamma
comes so the 13 million chess here come
half
from the june maturity half from the
next maturities so we still have this
bullish momentum that is here
what else i wanted to show you yeah in
terms of volatility we are still at very
high volatility
guys 330 i mean you know this now is
very steady market makers are ready for
the next move and it's going to come
so no not more information here yes what
i wanted to show you guys
so this is the distribution of the open
interest
so in yellow you have the number of
shares of the total
open interest on amc now let me show you
just
how the june maturity is looking because
the dune maturity is the one
that might create the gamma uh in the
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
because
the shorter the maturity is the higher
the gamma is
so just on june it's looking like this
so the gym maturity looks like this so
you need to multiply this by hundreds so
basically here it's six
million shares and what is interesting
is to see where we have
those uh gamma positions those call
positions that are creating the gamma
so right now amc is here at 16. so here
you can see at 70
73 we have 3 million shares then
103 million shares so those two levels
if we go close to it or through this
tomorrow
or the day after tomorrow on the 18th
even worse i mean for the market makers
better for us
then it means that this is going to
create some strong
moves up like very strong like you know
they're gonna panic and they're gonna
buy
massively three million shares what is
the delta of the hundred
strike call if the delta is zero it
means they need to buy the total number
of shares
so the hundred strike is here the delta
is four percent so they need to buy
three million so that is six percent of
three million so roughly three million
shares all right guys
so you can see that this is what is
going to create this
momentum and regarding here i don't have
uh the
14th of june data yet it's going to be
released in one or two weeks
so i don't have new information the
total uh short interest
was 21 as of the 28th of may i'm pretty
sure it's higher now
and the synthetic short is 21 so we have
a total of 41
short interest synthetic and regular
i'm not here taking into account the
naked shorts guys
and you know i know there are a lot of
naked shorts
we can't do anything about it it's
actually maybe even good
for us because those naked shots they
would need to cut the position
at some point another interesting
information is that now the market cap
of amc is 26 billion
us dollars guys i'm keeping an eye on
this
if this gets really too high you know i
do some basic math
and just imagining there are 1 million
people
in the amc trade or let's say 10 million
people all right if there are 10 million
people
divided by 10 one two three four five
six
so it's like around two thousand six
hundred us dollar
per investor so it's possible it's
definitely
like uh some money that people can make
and i'm here taking
into account 10 million investors if we
go for example to 500
it's going to be tough to find all this
liquidity so i'm just keeping an eye on
it
we have maybe a cap on the market cap
around those levels you know
i think that is going to become very
hard to sustain for retail investors to
hold
to keep pushing the price action higher
when the market cap is going to be that
huge but for now we are good guys we are
good
you know it's like a few thousand
dollars per
person if i think if i assume that 10
million
amc investors and maybe there are more
and the more it goes higher
the more we're going to attract
investors and even now hedge funds and
you know some institutional clients they
are getting into the nc trades
and they are creating this buying power
as well
so that's it for me let me remind you
quickly my scenario guys
my scenario is that we connect we
correct slightly here
this is not my preferred scenario my
perfect scenario is this one
we go to 52 we bounce back we we do a
strong move up
probably to the 100 area not sure it's
going to be before june
before the 18th of june or not careful
as well when your options are expiring
is it that at the open or at the close
it depends and yeah i think we're going
to have this strong move up coming soon
235 so this is my view
let's see what is happening so hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys